I normally test the
latest beauty releases,
but today I'm testing out
the most-hyped products
from the early 2000s.
Let's start with some face products.
You know I had to include
the Maybelline Dream
Matte mousse foundation.
I feel like this was a lot
of people's first foundation,
mine included.
The formula is like this chunky mousse
with a bunch of little beads
that mattify the foundation.
I had to apply it with my
fingers at first, of course.
This foundation is just really odd to me.
It doesn't look like skin,
it doesn't look even, it's kind of drying,
and I can literally see the
color changing before my eyes.
I looked in the mirror, and
I was straight-up orange,
which I guess is fitting for this era.
Loose-powder mineral
makeup was such a big thing
in the 2000s.
I've never tried this bareMinerals
powder foundation before,
but I was actually pleasantly surprised.
I don't think it's as
buildable as it claims to be.
I feel like wearing it sheer looks better
than when you keep layering it.
But I liked how this looked on my skin.
It wasn't too drying,
but I did need a setting spray
to kind of melt it all in.
It feels weightless, which I really liked,
and everything I put on
top of this looked nice.
This also has SPF in
it, and it's talc-free.
This one triggered me
because I remember trying to
hide my acne with this stuff.
This is the Maybelline Cover
Stick corrector concealer.
It's a very thick formula,
it doesn't spread super easily,
and I can feel it on my skin.
It actually did a decent job
of covering everything
I needed it to cover,
but concealer formulas have just gotten
so much better than this.
Plus, the shade range is abysmal.
This one can stay in the past.
Bronzer usage was at an
all-time high in the 2000s,
and this one was always a popular choice.
This is the Nars Laguna bronzer.
It's a bronzer with a bunch
of gold shimmer in it.
Surprisingly, this looked
pretty smooth on the face,
even on top of that
Maybelline mousse foundation.
I thought that and the shimmer in it
would emphasize all of my
texture, but it didn't.
It also didn't look orange,
which I was also nervous about.
I also tried the classic
Benefit Cosmetics Hoola bronzer.
This one also applies very smoothly.
It has no shimmer in it, which I prefer.
I believe back then, Benefit
only had this one shade,
which was a little light for me.
The shade range still
hasn't expanded very much,
but this formula has held up.
This is the iconic Nars
blush in the shade Orgasm.
It's a peachy pink
with a ridiculous amount
of gold shimmer in it.
It claims to be buildable,
but the more I layered this
for that very 2000s pink-blush look,
the more textured my skin looked.
Like, this highlighted everything.
It's weird because I applied
a lot of the bronzer too,
which also has shimmer in it,
and it didn't look like this.
This blush is just not for me.
The Urban Decay Primer Potion
is a tried-and-true favorite.
The formula is thinner
than other eyeshadow bases I've tried.
I used a super-cheap CoverGirl
eyeshadow on top of this,
and I feel like it actually
made it look way better.
It makes it easy to blend out shadow.
I feel like it intensifies the color.
This is way overpriced,
but I think this is a
solid eyeshadow primer.
I saw so many of these
CoverGirl Eye Enhancers
in my research for this video.
They are just as chalky as they look.
The colors I chose may be the reason why,
but I can't talk about 2000s makeup
without some frosty blue
and white eyeshadow.
I think if I hadn't used them
on top of that Urban Decay Primer Potion,
they just would have not shown up.
Look at these swatches
on the back of my hand.
Just awful.
I will say that these
little sponge applicators
that I used to always throw away
actually apply the eyeshadow pretty well.
Now, these I still use all the time.
These are the Nyx jumbo eye pencils.
You can use them for so much.
As an eyeshadow, as a base
for eyeshadow, as an eyeliner.
These got a new life because of TikTok.
People were using them
to highlight certain areas of the face.
The formula is just super
creamy and easy to work with.
It is kind of a pain to
sharpen when you need to,
but I like the formula,
so I just deal with it.
I also still use and
really like this product.
This is the Urban Decay
Heavy Metal glitter eyeliner.
This does dry down quickly,
so you want to work fast,
but I think it adds the
prettiest sparkle to the eyes.
It's an easy way to use
glitter without any mess.
I will say this doesn't
layer very well, though.
It can get flaky if you layer it too much.
This is the MAC Smolder eyeliner.
I had to try this
specific eyeliner because
Avril Lavigne said she used
to use this one all the time.
I don't typically like wooden eyeliners,
but this one applied really well.
I have very sensitive eyes,
so my waterline gets super watery
when I try to apply eyeliner,
but the pigment actually
stuck with this one.
I actually used to love the
Maybelline Great Lash mascara.
I think the formula is pretty good.
It doesn't give a ton of length,
but it gives a nice amount of
volume without getting clumpy.
I honestly think if it
had a different brush,
I'd like it more.
In a sea of drugstore mascaras,
I don't think I'd go back to this one,
but I appreciate it for what it is.
DuWop Lip Venom is like
the OG lip plumper.
The tingle with this is pretty strong,
so if you hate that
feeling, I would avoid this.
It has this really nice cinnamony scent,
and it gives a really nice shine.
I like that it's a clear shade
that you can put on top of anything.
I noticed the plumping more on my top lip,
but it definitely plumps.
And I noticed that it also made
my lips look a bit smoother.
MAC lipsticks were so
popular in the 2000s.
Myth was, like, the concealer lip shade.
It's this super-pale nude
that looks ridiculous on
me without a lip liner.
And Snob is this pale pastel-pink color
that reminds me of Nicki Minaj.
Also looks awful on me.
Aside from the questionable color choices,
the MAC satin lipstick
formula still holds up.
It's comfortable on the lips,
and the formula is pretty buildable.
Also, the vanilla scent of MAC lipsticks
always takes me back.
This is the MAC lip liner in Spice.
I loved this.
This lip liner formula
applies really smoothly.
It doesn't dry down too quickly,
so you have time to blend.
I tried to do a
super-defined-lip-liner look
with that Myth lipstick,
and I actually loved it.
I'm definitely going to keep using this.
I've waited my whole life
to try the MAC Lipglass.
This is very thick, I will say.
I personally love the
feeling of a thick gloss.
I love how cushiony it is,
but you definitely feel this on the lips.
I know why they call it Lipglass,
because the shine this gives is unreal.
I'm in love with this.
I also tried a Lancôme Juicy Tube,
which is like the archnemesis
to the MAC Lipglass.
I picked this color
because it looks just like the one
that Gretchen Wieners uses.
It has a scent I really dislike.
It's kind of floral-perfume-y.
The actual formula is nice.
It's thinner than the Lipglass
but still really shiny and pretty.
I don't think this is
anything that special.
The Nars lip gloss in Turkish
Delight feels very 2000s.
It's this pale, milky pink color.
I think this used to be Kim
Kardashian's favorite gloss,
which, I don't know why.
This formula is kind of oily and thin.
I don't know if it used
to be a different formula,
but it's not very good now.
This color also settles into
the wrinkles on my lips,
so it's just not super flattering.
I could not do a 2000s makeup video
without mentioning Lip
Smacker's lip glosses.
They're more like a lip gloss for kids.
Like, my mom bought me these
before I was allowed to wear any makeup.
They're not actually a
good lip-gloss formula.
They feel like chicken grease on the lips,
but you know what?
They still smell and taste
just as good as you remember.
I would never buy these as
a serious lip-gloss option,
but using them again has
brought me so much joy.